foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thank you
for joining us America Jade warshaw
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five starting this hour is
going to be Anthony Anthony's with us in
Jackson Tennessee hi Anthony welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
uh my question today involves uh have to
do with paying off a mortgage or saving
up a down payment for a new house my
wife and I are we just became Consumer
Debt free and we will have our emergency
phone built up within the next two
months and I just wasn't sure uh if it's
better to build the equity in our
existing mortgage and I think we could
get it paid off within that two to three
year period or just save up a pile of
cash well congratulations way to go man
thank you feels good to get control
doesn't it it does 55 000 and 18 months
there's a student loans and uh car loan
way to go that's exciting
yes ma'am thank you so the question is
you're thinking ahead to paying off your
mortgage am I understanding that
correctly
yes either that or getting a sizable
down payment for cash I don't know which
one would be more beneficial well once
you've got your emergency fund saved and
walking down the baby steps then you're
going to start putting that 15 away for
retirement right do you have anything
with kids college coming up do you have
kids uh we we do have a one-year-old
little girl we haven't really started
anything on her yet because we're
getting out of debt that's right and
when the time comes you'll want to make
sure that you're doing baby step five so
opening is something uh an Esa or 529
for her making sure you're putting some
money aside from that and then when it's
time to start paying down the mortgage I
would not do a lump sum and throw it at
it I would make the payments extra
payments whenever you have the money put
it on to the mortgage and here's why
this is this is the Jade way of saying
this because whenever you have a stack
of money just sitting there it gets real
tempting to use oh you know what I think
we might need a new vehicle or oh you
know what we do need a vacation to
Hawaii right it's easy to think that
that money can be earmarked for
something else and so I like the idea of
just piling it onto the mortgage when
the time comes that Waits out of your
hands and it's building you know equity
and it's that for savings account
um for savings that's what a guy used to
work for called it Anthony said when you
pay extra on the mortgages for savings
account because it's real hard I mean
it's all you can do it but it's a lot of
trouble yeah to get the equity out of
your house to go buy a bass boat
it's not hard to do it out of your
savings account and so
um it's just you know you're going to
stay on task for the move up in-house
and your your the good news the weird
thing is about paying down your mortgage
it feels like the money's gone but it's
not it's just saved in the equity
because you get the money when you sell
the house it's not like you're consuming
the money like you spent it or something
it's not gone and so it's just you know
what is a better place I like the forest
aspect of it and uh and the other thing
is when you do get the house paid off
plans might have changed that's right
that's absolutely true and so even if
they don't and that's fine I'm not
saying they have to change but if they
don't change and you're going to sell
the house and sell it they'll give you a
big old we'll check it to closing
because you ain't got any mortgage yeah
and off we go so yeah Forest Savings
Plan it's a good idea to trick yourself
into as many smart things as you can
absolutely yeah audit I say automate
smart and so when you automate those
extra payments or when you just
automatically put those towards debt
it's a smart habit that's automated now
the only time Dave that I would stack up
a pile of money to pay off a debt is if
there was some sort of deal that I was
getting like with if you had a private
student loan and they said hey if if you
pay a lump sum we'll give you some off
that's the only time I might stack up
well or a 401k loan you can't pay extra
on it you can only pay the minimum or a
lump sum one of the two so you have to
stack up yeah that's a 401k loan
something along those lines then you
have to yeah but other than that I agree
yeah and you know hey guys it's a good
idea I got a bunch of Auto draft for
good things like going into mutual funds
Auto draft going into savings Auto draft
automatically paying everything so I
never miss a discount on all utilities
everything's full auto uh has been since
before it was cool yeah before digital
yeah you know I've been on auto
everything and you you know what I just
said is I'm going to automate smart and
make stupid hard that's good let me call
out something though because I've been
there when you went from struggle slices
to a non-struggle situation back when it
was struggle slices I hated automating
things because I never knew what my
money was looking like and somebody
could pull that money out of my account
overdraw my account and so when we
finally got to the situation where okay
like money's good life is good that was
a hard transition to make it was like
the old brain going no no no no no no no
no and then the new brain has to go yes
yes we we manage our money now like this
is good so it's not it's not I'm not
living crisis to Christ yes I don't have
to control the crisis I can let this
thing flow and so yeah I haven't paid a
utility bill in years that's great I
look so direct you know except Direct
Auto auto
uh deduct or whatever the flip you call
it and you know so it's just yeah in I
don't know decades like forever simplify
it and show yeah David Bach talks about
that on an old book that came out back
when uh my first best seller came out
financial piece he came out a couple
years later with a book called automatic
millionaire he talks you know just Auto
drafting into your Mutual on auto that's
the beauty of the 401K comes out your
paycheck you don't even miss it that's
right and uh it's the only reason that
the income tax system in America works
please talk about that David you know I
mean if you had a guy if you had a guy
named Matthew that was at your office
and when you got your check you got cash
you didn't get a check and you had to
walk out and hand Matthew
the tax collector I like what you did
there yeah you see how I did that yeah
yeah if you had if you had to walk out
and hand Matthew the tax collector
actual cash out of your check that he
was going to then supposedly take to the
federal government
there would be a revolution in this
country with pitchforks and torches but
the sheep have been lulled to sleep by
Auto draft out of your check and they
sure wouldn't be giving him extra to get
back later as a refund
you know Matthew I'm gonna I'm just
gonna leave a little with you Matthew
the tax collector you look like a good
guy I'm just going to leave a little
extra with you and come April you can
hand it back to me with no interest
that's a really good point it would end
all tax refunds okay there would be no
overpayment by God because every dollar
coming out of your hand would squeak
every dollar coming out of your hand
would cause anger every dollar coming
out of your hand would cause you to vote
again correctly oh my God and he'll
cause you to fire a whole bunch of
people that can't seem to balance their
books oh my God it would change a little
trillion here a trillion there you know
and then pretty soon we get into some
serious money wow oh wow look Dave I
just want to be able to start a sentence
with my first best seller
that's what you did it's coming before
you I love I love that coming before you
know it my first special something
before you know
that's after you've had a second one
right is that how that works that's how
it works well they're coming they're
coming they're coming I got a feeling
Jay I got a feeling this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us
a lot of people who tune into every
single episode that we do thank you for
that and you know
truth you can answer the questions
faster than we can
but you're still stressed you're still
stuck why is that because it turns out
knowing what to do isn't the deal doing
it is the deal
you can know what to do and not do it
and have no success whatsoever thus the
problem with only knowing application is
part of wisdom and The Proven way to
change your behavior with money is by
taking Financial Peace University
it's our nine week class or nine lesson
Class A lot of people do it nine weeks
you get with a superhero called a
coordinator that will encourage you and
hold you accountable act as your
personal trainer as you go through and
you're in a class either virtually or in
a group class over at your church
that's why this class has worked for
over 10 million people and after nine
weeks you will never handle money the
same way again the typical person has an
8 000 turnaround in 90 days
that's right they typically pay off
fifty three hundred dollars in debt in
the first 90 days and save twenty seven
hundred dollars in the first 90 days
eight thousand dollars pretty good
turnaround that's called Roi return on
investment Financial Peace University
check it out ramseysolutions.com FPU
ramsesolutions.com
FPU calendra is with us in Shreveport
hey Calandra welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you for having me certainly how
can we help
uh I have a question about uh baby step
number one and uh I kind of want you to
give me a bit of a critique on if you
think I'm a little serious about this or
not
all right what's going on
okay so I am halfway through baby step
number one working on saving that
thousand dollars and unfortunately in my
security well really in all of
Shreveport Bossier and some of the
Architects uh our power was out and so I
had to throw away my whole fridge
basically and refill it and it set me
back a bit but that's neither really
here nor there the electricity is back
on great but
um
it's like every time I start to save my
money up something like this happens to
me and I'm not really complaining about
it I'm a little frustrated but I am
starting to wonder if maybe I just am
not making enough money
to even get to the expense uh right now
I'm making two thousand dollars a month
I live really really cheap
um I don't have a lot of expenses but I
do have a ton of debt I am making like I
said 2 000 a month I pay 650 every month
for my rent
um a couple hundred dollars a month like
237 a month for my car plus another 100
for my insurance a hundred dollars for
my clothes uh you know things like that
how old are you it is about 300 26. yeah
I
for the critique this is I do want you
to make more money but specifically for
baby step one you got like the the thing
the thing that's gonna keep life from
happening to you on this and you know
you take one step forward two steps back
it's speed you've got to come in like a
wrecking ball and just
pull through this I mean you're selling
stuff you're going so hard in the paint
most people save this within 30 days
like that I wanted to ask you how long
have you been on baby step one about two
thousand dollars is you can't do it yeah
that's what I'm saying she's gotta go
she's gotta pick up all the work do all
the things the babysitting the house
I'm a banker
or get a bank
full-time
doing what
I'm just a teller okay all right yeah
I'm not like one of those loading
Specialists or anything like that I just
got this job like two months ago okay uh
well not two months ago like in February
high school education day that I started
yep uh I'm back in college I'm going for
my uh Associates in business and then I
will get a better paying job and then I
will continue on with my bachelor's in
business how are you paying for the
associates
um actually my job is paying for it
that's great great great
yeah so there's a path you have a path
in front of you to earning more
which is good but for the here and now
we've got to find ways to earn more and
I'm not saying that I I like that you're
on a path to earning more but
you gotta pick up more hours somehow
maybe not obviously maybe not at the
bank I'm not sure what they offer there
let me ask you something okay
um
when you took the banker job or the
teller job at the bank
um
the um obviously you were looking for
work at that point what were you doing
before that
before that I was a full-time artist a
painter and muralist I was teaching this
part-time job uh teaching art to
children and like um okay so you took
the let me let me see if I can get in
your head for a second did you take this
job part-time job did you let me see if
I can get in your head a second did you
take this job to uh because it felt like
it was like you were like being an
artist you might have felt a little bit
irresponsible part-time and all that
this is like a responsible big girl job
I'm gonna get on a track here to build a
career
no you actually took that job
back in the day I was in school for
graphic design and I was paying for
everything out of pocket I'm the first
person in my family to go to college and
when I reached out to get support from
not only my family but for my counselors
as well
um
I didn't really get a lot of good
support I didn't get very much feedback
and I was doing everything on my own and
then I think you're I think you're
amazing the thing I'm thinking about is
um
I I would like for you to do something
that maybe is not as
um
I don't know
um I'd like for you to make twice as
much money as something that doesn't
sound as fun as banking or sound as
professional as banking if you were to
clean houses and make forty eight
thousand or you can be a teller and uh
be twenty four thousand I'll take the
clean houses right now okay look you're
creative you have a skill set and you
have an offering that the average person
can't do there is a way to that you can
monetize that in some way and make more
money at per hour than you're doing
right now you agree wholeheartedly I am
I applaud your move in the direction
you're going and I applaud all the
decisions you're making I think you're
an incredible young lady it's fun
talking to you I would like for you to
find a way to make a have a a job that
might not make everybody around you
think you're cool or proud or whatever
but don't give a crap that makes more
money right now you need some more money
yeah if you could go make 48 000 on your
day job and make another twenty thousand
on your side job teaching art to kids
and create some kind of uh uh mentoring
program or some kind of uh uh uh
tutoring program or something along
those lines summer workshops yeah you
get you get paid sure and you know if I
could get your Inc like and then that
increases your speed because part of the
problem is is that you're not making any
money that's right I mean what's your
it's not a put down because I think
you're moving in the right Direction and
um and you don't have good
uh people around you to tell you to go
do this or go do that and so we're going
to be those people yep okay we're going
to help you I'm going to do a couple
things one is uh I'm going to put you
through Financial Peace University our
nine-week program I also want you to
take Ken Coleman with the Ramsey
networks he has a show on career and on
jobs and he has an assessment a career
assessment it's thirty dollars but I'm
going to give it to you okay and I'm
also going to give you his book from
paycheck to purpose I'm going to load
you up kiddo because I think you got
huge potential and we're going to come
around you put our arms around you and
love you hug you and say go get them
tiger get them and you call back here
anytime and remind us of this
conversation and we'll talk to you and
and help you we'll be the ones in your
corner but right now I would rather you
be in a job that is not as um uh I don't
know what the right word is it's not
respectable that's not the right word
but it's not it's not as professional
sounding yeah you know she's a free
spirit she needs a free spirit
reflective Bankers let me tell you about
banking in general okay banking big
title little money
clearly just in general and tell her
bottom of that Barrel big title little
money lots of lots of walking around
like I'm doing something no money so
when someone says they're a banker I
always Snicker this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Daniel and Danielle are with
us hey guys how are you good good how
are you doing better than we deserve
welcome good to have you guys where do
y'all live Brunswick Georgia oh yeah fun
just down the road well welcome to
Nashville how much debt have you all
paid off 237 thousand dollars yeah how
long did that take eight years whoa okay
and your range of income during that
time oh uh 80 000 to start with
uh 140 now cool what do you all do for a
living we're Foresters very good good
that's cool
so 237 thousand eight years I'm gonna
guess and say that might be your house
yes sir student loans family loans
loan the mortgage
how old are you two 34 and 33. all right
very cool so you start this around 25
years old and you knock out everything
student loans and the house what's this
house worth
uh 300 000 now okay wow wow very cool
good for you how's it feel to be free
relieving yes yes I love it been working
on it a long time I hear you I hear you
very cool so what started all this eight
years ago is that when you all got
married
actually right after we got married yeah
we took took Financial Peace at a local
church and uh since then we got on it
pretty hard and uh had three kids in the
meantime uh We've taught the class three
times three times oh thank you ourselves
uh and hoping to maybe do it again this
year wow that's very very so how do you
even so you took Financial Peace at the
church how did you find out about it was
it your church or did somebody tell you
about it so when we first started
getting married
um I'm the one that brought the debt
into the marriage so I had forty seven
thousand dollars in student loan debts
and I knew that we needed to tackle it
and he was on board we had a friend who
actually went to the church that hosted
it that said hey you might want to check
this out and kind of heard about you a
little bit so we thought it would be a
good opportunity you know when we first
get married after the Christmas holidays
you know was go through this and it was
a goal for both of us to pay off the
student loan debt before we started
having our family so that really kind of
set off the Journey very very cool so
she brought forty seven thousand dollars
of student loan debt into it Daniel
what I mean tell me just be honest I had
I had no no student loans thankfully uh
parents that paid for my college which
is what we're trying to do for our kids
yeah I was all smarter than me so and
yeah I had scholarships uh but we did uh
borrow money to make a down payment on
the house or I could buy it so we did
have that yeah
but you were like her that's my debt
like we're gonna go get this yeah
he wasn't really quite on board for us
we had very different mindsets when it
comes to money like I you know had
student loan debt so I was used to
saying a hundred dollars in the bank
account and be like I got a hundred
dollars I'm good and he was not quite
that way I got it so you were like I'll
drain down my account pay this thing and
for him that was like this is very
uncomfortable it was very uncomfortable
for about two years honestly but lived
off of his salary and my whole salary uh
went to the student loan debts so I
worked as a county Forester which
doesn't make a ton of money through the
state and he worked Private Industry a
Forester so we just completely lived off
of that and then I'm just you know we
already I was already used to living off
a hundred bucks so it wasn't really that
hard
that is very cool very cool good for you
guys way to go y'all okay now you've led
the class you're getting ready to lead
it again you've been through it and uh
in Financial Peace University people are
going to come up to you and they go you
paid off 237 000. how did you do that
what's the secret what are you doing
be diligent
patience patient and diligent just takes
time eight years a long time it's a long
time was it worth it it was worth it yes
our oldest is five we have a middle
child that's four and our youngest is
two we paid off our we paid for two new
cars with cash
um yeah that's all of them right there
wow so the youngest one now she's mean
she'll get you but um through all of it
like when we're teaching I mean we try
to really help those that are going
through it the the comparison game
because that's where everyone's got to
get you you know just going out to lunch
here is not a big deal for this and so
really being tunneled in Focus because
some of those even closest to you may
not necessarily understand what it is
you're doing while you're doing it you
know live for the moment not for
necessarily worry about that down the
line so we try to help them go through
and understand be patient you know be
diligent stick to the plan keep your
vision on the long term so who were who
were your cheerleaders like who were the
people that kept you guys focused
encourage you kept you going did you
have those people I would say it was uh
starting out it was each other uh and
then as we've taught the class and had
folks uh but while teaching the class
first of all every two years is a great
reminder this is about that point in
time two years later we were starting to
let the wheels get a little wobbly and
then we'd take the class and we'd be
fired up again that's right
um so that's been huge for us just from
an accountability standpoint and then uh
those folks that we've seen go through
the class that keep keep checking in and
Friends uh now that we're checking in on
them and just kind of keep trying on the
prize so yes it does get the right get
the right peer group around you that's
right yeah very cool good job guys Your
Heroes I'm so proud of you very neat
thanks for coming all the way up here to
do your debt free scream too and thanks
for leading Financial Peace University
it's a big deal it's been a bucket list
for about seven years so well we're
honored we're honored to have be on your
bucket list and to have you here and
you're a very very cool couple very well
done y'all very well done a hundred
percent debt free making 140 no house
payment no nothing 33 years old living
on three hundred thousand dollar house
how much is in your retirement accounts
I haven't looked at it in the last
couple months probably
probably
one 200 between the two of us that's
great yeah well on your way so you're at
a half million dollar net worth already
and you're 33 years old so you'll be
millionaires by the time you're 38. it's
the goal yeah all the kids college
savings account set up and millionaire
Foresters oh come on not something you
hear every day they're cool
girls usually go into forestry for the
money it's not it's not usually the big
money right
yeah it depends on which part you're
going oh she's like don't be deceived
we're getting choices now we've got
choices yeah everybody needs toilet
paper
we're not going out of business that's
for sure well that's good well hey it's
so good to have y'all I'm so proud of
you very very well done and uh Future
Baby Steps millionaires right here in
front of us very good stuff all right
Dan oh we've got the uh baby steps
millionaires book for you The Total
Money Makeover book for you and the
another financial piece of University
membership you'll be able to give that
to someone who's in need get them in
your class and on us and our way of
saying thanks and our way of saying
congratulations so that's the live and
give box we'll send that with you as you
go very good stuff fun fun what a cool
couple Daniel and Danielle
237 thousand dollars paid off house and
everything by the time they're 33 did it
in eight years making 80 to 140 count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
yeah wow wow that's great that's exactly
what this is for it is I love that they
kept coordinating the classes to stay
motivated I hold you accountable because
you cannot be the typical human cannot
coordinate a class while not doing it so
it the hip you can't be a hypocrite most
people most people have a sense of Honor
a sense of integrity and they know that
they don't want to you know you don't
want to be around if you're going to
bail if you're gonna jump off the wagon
not fall off the wagon you know you
don't want to be around people on the
wagon I guess yeah absolutely and it
just goes to show I mean we talk about
all the time the importance of getting
in Financial Peace University because
it's so extensive what you're learning
in those classes you can't
you can suck up a lot of it in one round
but you need to go a couple of rounds to
really get it all sucked in you remember
it you're doing it you know because it's
seven baby steps here you know what you
remember from lesson one when you from
from step one when you first come in is
different when you get to Baby Steps
you're different you're different by the
time you get there and so yeah hearing
it again you hear it with different eyes
hear it with different ears see it with
different eyes and um you know it's like
I read us read the same Bible story 10
years later yeah you see something
completely different that's right you
didn't see before the story didn't
change the words on the page didn't
change you change that's right that's
what happens this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
all right
Jade Washington Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Holly
is in Bentonville Arkansas hey Holly
welcome to the Ramsey Show
how are you guys better than we deserve
what's up
okay so I have
um made a lot of changes over the last
year I've increased my salary from 40
000 to 82 000 days with a 15 yearly
bonus I've paid off my car I bought a
house
um I've never had a credit card but I do
have about 30 000 in student loans and I
am wondering how I should prioritize my
bucket so student loans savings
emergency funds and investing and also
some tips for someone who's never
created like a true budget before and
has never been like a stable money
environment
very good so you are asking all the
right questions you are so smart awesome
that's what I'm talking about
um yeah this is great
um so the 30k in student loans is it
just one lump sum or is it broken to
like a billion loans
it's a couple
well what I would do if that's your only
debt I would list it I would start with
that
um I'd list it from smallest to largest
and start attacking that debt now by the
way do you have any savings laying
around of any kind
oh well funny story I had 12 000 when
I've had two car engine failures within
the last month shoot so now I'm down to
about I know now I'm down to about 6
000. okay
um so I kind of have some left so what I
would do I'm what I'm doing here is I'm
walking through our baby steps I would
keep a thousand dollars set aside that's
just your starter emergency fund just
like quick rainy day fund so that's
thing one and then the money left so you
said you had six thousand put a thousand
aside take the other money and throw it
at your student loans and get a head
start on that and then continually work
to pay those student loans off so that's
kind of like your big Focus right now
um and then after that we were just
walking down the steps through the baby
steps after you've paid off the debt
then you can beef up your emergency fund
to about three to six months of expenses
and then after that we would start the
investing process
um so and it goes on down the line into
seven baby steps I'm guessing you're a
new listener with us so so if I say
anything that you're like what the heck
is that Jade just stop me so Holly what
we figured out is is this money thing
what you is exactly what you discovered
it all comes at you at once and you're
like where do I start
and that was that was kind of your
question in a sense right and so we
figured out you can do anything if you
do it a baby step at a time one little
baby step at a time you can eat how you
eat an elephant a bite at a time right
and so we broke down good personal
financial planning 25 or 30 years ago
into Progressive seven baby steps and
baby step one is thousand dollars little
starter emergency fund everything else
goes at baby step two until you're done
and baby step two is pay off all your
debt except your house list your debts
in this case your student loans you've
got sounds like three of them smallest
to largest what's the smallest one
about three thousand good I want you to
pay and how much did you have in savings
six thousand I want you to pay it off
today
okay then baby steps yeah then your debt
snowball because we're gonna go down to
a thousand okay then throw everything
down to a thousand at the next debt and
we're going to continue to attack these
deaths because when you only have a
thousand in your account it's a little
scary right just me saying it you went
whoa right and yeah that little bit of
fear motivates you to get very very very
intense on knocking these debts out very
very quickly beans and rice rice and
beans Scorch Earth lifestyle living on a
detailed budget by the way we're gonna
help you with that too in just a minute
okay and then
then what you'll do is
um uh as soon as all your debts are paid
off smallest to largest now with no
payments in the world and a newfound
control doing your budget you then do
what Jade said and go to baby step three
which is three to six months of expenses
as your emergency fund a fully funded
proper emergency fund one thousand
dollars is not enough okay and then once
you've done that now you've laid the
foundation you got control of your
income and you've got a baseline to keep
people off of you in terms of the
emergency fund now we can start building
wealth and baby step four is fifteen
percent of your income into retirement
five is kids college if you don't have
kids that one doesn't apply six is you
pay off your house early seven is with
no house payment no payments in the
world money going into your retirement
account there's nothing left to do but
become very wealthy we're teaching
people how to become millionaires in 12
to 15 years doing this with your income
if you'll lean into this we can do it
maybe a little quicker than that because
you're doing really really good so
that's how those things work and that's
the background on what you're doing we
also developed several years ago and
have continued to iterate literally the
world's best budgeting app and it's free
to use it's called every dollar okay so
just go online and download the every
dollar app it's going to teach you to
give every one of your dollars a name
and an assignment so that it behaves
because money will not behave unless you
make it behave I know that's right and
just you know when you start this budget
just give yourself patience because if
you've not been a budgeter before it
takes time to get used to what the
amounts are what this feels like it
takes time to learn how to say no to
purchases so just you know give yourself
your first month you'll suck yeah yeah
you'll just blow it out of the water and
then your second month you'll start to
work a little bit the third month it
takes three months for it to really work
good yep but the budgeting app's free
we're going to send you a book called
The Total Money Makeover sold about 10
million of those and it's the it's the
detailed nuanced thing on the baby steps
exactly how to do it and why to do it
and that's why it sold so many copies
because people want to know exactly what
you wanted to know you're asking all the
right questions very good yeah you're
pretty cool hang on uh Austin will sign
a pickup will get you a book delivered
and just jump online and pick up the
every dollar app it's completely free to
start trying it and uh and I think
you'll see what we're talking about
pretty quickly it's it's very robust
very easy to use
um
what is the crap they always say about
apps uh that I don't ever they're
intuitive yeah and it's not intuitive
for me but this one is you know
you know who's not tech savvy it is yeah
I have a fit if it's not intuitive me
too uh but they always tell me that when
I'm frustrated David's intuitive what
does that mean I don't have intuition
maybe your intuition what does that mean
what are you saying about me you're
saying I'm not intelligent no worse I
don't have intuition every dollar is
intuitive even for those of us that
quote lack into it when you look Apple
up when you look Apple up in the uh in
the Greek it means frustrated I mean
it's just for me but I'm a boomer and I
don't know anything so I don't know all
you cool kids all got that stuff and I
will I do want you to keep in mind that
there's one place that there was a bite
taken out of the Apple that was fatal
and that was in the Garden of Eden so
and that Apple has a bite out of it I'm
just saying so you might want to look at
that logo and think about that what do I
know though that is funny Dave you're
sounding like a conspiracy theorist up
in here no not at all I'm not being
serious at all none of you believe I
have have apple and there's one right
here there you go I'm laying right here
and so and I'm I'm with you I'm I I
diligently hire people to teach me to
work it that's so funny look I will say
as a person I don't love technology the
only reason I have it is because I have
to Sam buys my phone every dollar it's
if I can you can do it I think anybody
can the way I feel about is Rachel can
do it oh and that's how I know it's easy
it's talk about her behind her back but
yeah she's she's the spokesman for every
day and that's the yeah yeah that's
that's how we know it's easy I like it
because there's a couple of new things
that they implemented oh that paycheck
yes
completely changed everything yeah if
you guys have been off of every dollar
for a couple years or you look you're
one of those people download the app
never got rid of it like never went back
and looked at it in eight years the only
y'all keep apps around like you don't
clean your closets I mean what is with
you people but anyway if you're one of
those people you got to go back and open
the thing back up get the update because
paycheck planning makes all the
difference your regular income this
solves all your problems if you're like
on commission are like you know getting
sporadic income solves that problem it's
got that Financial roadmap thing where
you can really use everything just
project and see you can see how long
it's going to take you to get out of
here we know it worked because we use
fancy words like engagement is Ah that's
right that's right that has nothing to
do with getting married and it just has
to do with the use of the app apparently
engagement is up that's good not number
of people getting engaged on every
dollar but engagement of the actual app
so there you go
see this is what happens when you have a
boomer running a technology company this
is exactly how it unfolds yeah this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they really love and
create actual amazing relationships yep
mental health you got it money you got
it career you got it jobs we talk about
it we're going to mess with every area
of your life if at all possible Jade
wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Samuel in Seattle starts this hour hi
Samuel how are you
hey Dave I'm doing well how are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world
I've been talking about buying some
property
um we just we think it's the right time
to do it we just don't know we're kind
of nervous about making a purchase that
big
um so I want to know what you thought
about making a purchase for land or
maybe even a house on a piece of land
that
um
kind of in our price range
so um are you out of debt
um so we only have one piece of debt and
it's a fifth wheel that we're currently
living in right now
um we do travel for work so that is our
residents
um and we owe about forty six thousand
dollars on that okay job ones get that
clear
before you buy you need to be debt free
uh even if you're living in it it's
going down in value and so it is
Consumer Debt
okay and especially if you're living in
it it's going down in value it's
Consumer Debt and so yeah you need to
get rid of that what's your household
income
um right now it's about a hundred
thousand good for you okay and that's
your only debt no student loans no
nothing else
correct very good okay cool well you can
knock it out pretty quick then because
you guys live pretty Frugal you're
traveling what do you do for a living
uh we're travel nurses wow why are you
making only a hundred
um so right now I'm off my wife we just
had a baby eight months ago
I would have thought I was thinking 200.
yeah okay makes more sense one of you is
working okay so and yeah usually you're
making around 200 right
yes yeah is she gonna go back to work or
is is this the plan is she staying home
with the kid
um So the plan is to have her stay at
home with the kid and then you work
full-time so the income will stay about
the same unless
um we're able to be around family where
we can both pick a contract somewhere
then that could boost our income for a
short time
um so otherwise the plan is for her to
stay at home
um okay so tell me about this land are
you are you going to change everything
with the baby then and go live in this
house and get rid of the fifth wheel
no so we're
the plan is
we have somewhere to go back to
um whenever we're traveling we take a
break we go back to that piece of land
and we're paying on something that's
actually going to be ours and eventually
in the future
you put hookups out there and as a
temporary measure and and as long as you
decide to live on the road and babies
living with you and the wife's living
with you in the fifth wheel and here we
go
yes okay all right okay that's cool is
it are you trying to do enough land to
where more than one person could hook up
or is it just for you guys
we're looking at like a minimum of three
acres but uh any amount of land as long
as it's the right price yeah um is going
to be fine with us you know eventually
you know we could maybe add on to that
more RV sites and help other people to
do the same thing that we do and maybe
make a little money off of that as well
that's good what's something like that
cost I I don't know where you are yeah
there's a hundred percent of location
location and location establishes price
so um yeah I uh uh
okay I'm gonna treat this like anything
else it's just a matter we're not going
to buy a house we're not going to buy
land to do this deal until we're debt
free have an emergency fund and have a
good down payment and then you're going
to put the land on a 15-year fixed where
you pay off pay it off uh as soon as
possible where the payments no more than
a fourth of your take-home pay uh and
save up the cash to do the improvements
to do the hookups okay after you after
you get on the land okay uh and you can
you guys can do every bit of this
because you're still Square in the
middle of the travel Adventure
and as that Adventure winds down and we
want more permanent routes that's what
you're seeing out there in the future a
few years probably
um then you know you by then you will be
easily into this land to have the
hookups done we start talking about
drawing house plants you know if you
wanted to and and you know sell the old
used fifth wheel that we used to use
back when we were travel nurses and so
on you know and so you're gonna you're
gonna you know that's probably your five
ten year reality that's kind of why I
was wondering if he saw it as a piece of
land that other RVs would
also be using
or was it just for them because if it's
just for them I can see them converting
it into land for a home yeah but if it's
more of like this business model where
do you see what I'm saying
I would lean personally I would tell you
not to do RVs in your own backyard I
mean I just tell you just if you're
gonna have three acres that's not enough
room uh yeah personally I'm just gonna
say I mean you're raising a family
you've been so
uh utilitarian
you know we're living on the road you've
been doing it for money and there's
nothing wrong with that but there's
gonna you're gonna reach a point look at
your quality of life is what you're
after next and if I'm going to do an RV
park later I'm going to do that as a
separate Venture after I've got my home
settled and that's a separate thing and
instead of just plugging them in people
right next door to me I I think by then
that uh there's good you're going to
reach a point the fund's gonna wear off
of that yeah but when the baby gets
older and maybe school age yeah I mean
when your kids are in college you don't
want you're not you don't want you're
going to be living a fifth wheel and
you're not gonna be living with fifth
wheel with people living next door and
fifth wheel for sure it's just I mean
unless you're very unusual that would be
highly unlikely so um just just so kind
of think about it out there in the
future A good rule of thumb by the way
for everybody is the further into the
future your plan works the better the
plan is that's good yeah you know and
unless you just say it's a temporary
thing I'm doing this for a year like I
know guys and gals that uh you know
after the Iraqi War there's a lot of
people did contract work in the sandbox
and they'd go over there and make like
serious money four or five times what
they could have made back in the States
doing whatever kind of work whether it's
military or military related or
construction or whatever it was but to
get Workers they were paying and they'd
say okay I'm gonna take a year but I'm
gonna go Mike bank and then I'm gonna
come back home yeah and that's but it's
but they weren't saying I'm gonna go
work in a sandbox for 40 years well
that's an important that's an important
point you you've got to be somebody
who's looking ahead otherwise those
transitions that naturally occur in life
can sneak up on you and you feel like
you're not ready
um Sam and I for years we traveled
internationally 35 40 weeks out of the
year and even though we were truly truly
enjoying that in the moment I had to
look around the corner both of us didn't
go okay like what's this going to look
like if we have kids yeah and you got to
be planning okay what's it what's that
pivot look like to get out of that and
to get into something else and just
knowing that life has seasons and you
know career and that helps you with your
financial decisions because real estate
is a very permanent decision yes it's
not permanent but it is a very permanent
yes it's harder to jump in and out of a
piece of real estate than it is a car or
a fifth wheel right you know so very
very good stuff well done good job
Samuel congratulations on the baby
everything's going good you got a good
plan man thanks for calling in this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
Hollow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today the
Ramsey Show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is the
place to find Reliable help for your
home from trusted locally owned
businesses like Glass Doctor Mr Handyman
and shelf Genie great folks over at
neighborly visit neighborly.com today
and find home experts that are available
to you all right today's question comes
from Christine in Virginia she says what
is the difference between a bear market
and a bull market and why are they
called Bull and Bear I don't know how to
take these into consideration when I'm
investing that's a really good question
and I feel like you hear that a lot
um it's basically the terms to talk
about when the market is up versus when
it's down right it's like the 20 swing
between it being up and things looking
great and everybody's like optimistic
and happy and it being down on which it
had been
better part of 2022
and even into 2021 I believe and
everybody's like oh no we're all dying
and it's a bear Market which you know
I've always I don't know if I'm right
about this but I've always just thought
okay it's a bear Market everything's
asleep like it's hibernating because
that's hibernating well I read a I read
something that said that it's based on
the two animals are based on how they
attack you so a bull
like bores you with his horns up right
and a bear slashes you and goes down
I don't know I've never heard that I had
never heard that either that's why I
shared a little bit I was more with the
run you know bull in a china shop yeah
you know run crazy yeah and charge right
and uh the bear is hibernating yeah cold
yeah so a bear is an extended down
marketable is an extended up morning
that's right short amounts too and it
shouldn't change if you're in baby step
before it shouldn't change anything
about the way that you're investing
um you invest when the Market's down and
you invest when the market is up and
that's just part of it and over time it
balances itself out and you know that's
called dollar cost averaging yes when
the Market's down the shares are on sale
oh God the stock market's down when
people say that I go oh great the stock
market's down they're on sale yeah and
so it's like get get it you know you
know flash sale on Friday they're down
you know jump in get get while the
getting's good that's right and when
they're up it means that all those
shares you bought are doing really good
so there's always something to be happy
about if you think of their proper
perspective the only reason you freak
out when the Market's down is if you
think it's going to stay down forever
which there's no historical debt I mean
historical there is some hysterical but
there's no historical data that
indicates that there's lots of
hysterical data that indicates that so
let's talk about I have an angle that I
want to discuss this all right so let's
say you are you want a dollar cost
average which is you're just putting
that same amount you know month after
month or whatever if you are a person
with irregular income what's the best
way to automate that like we talked
about we've talked about before just
like automating these smart habits
what's the best way to automate that if
you're not sure exactly what your income
is going to be
well I mean you'd have to automate an
amount that you are sure about because
otherwise you got to change it every
time but then at the end of the year
you'd have to do a make good yeah you
got to make good a couple times a year
yeah and look up and go I gotta play a
little ketchup and those are the times
if I'm gonna put in if I think I'm gonna
put in twenty thousand dollars and but
my income is very volatile I might
automate 10 000 of it or 15 000 of it
and then do the make good on the other
five and that's when this has got
down I'm
not keep going you gotta you gotta stick
with a constant consistent investment
plan
100 percent
all the research all the data of the
people that jump in and jump out they
don't keep up with a constant piece
that's right you can jump in jump out
jump in jump out some because you're
using way too much emotion a hundred
percent of the time when you jump in and
jump out that's right and you're not
using good data and you're not doing
good long-term thinking
you're using freak out as your
investment advisor and don't use freak
out freakout's a bad investment advisor
well that's one of the reasons that it's
good to have an investment advisor to
help you not be the Freak Out
exactly so you don't fall for that the
dollar cost averaging is simply if if
the the shares that you're buying in a
mutual fund are down because the
Market's down then a thousand dollars
that month or a hundred dollars or 200
that month whatever it is buys more
shares that's right they're down it buys
fewer shares when the shares are up and
the Market's doing well but the shares
that you already own are worth more so
it's like a sale so you end up with you
know that you end up with a benefit of
having ridden the roller coaster that's
right you got the thrill and you're
perfectly safe
everything's okay so it's all good no
one gets hurt on a roller coaster except
uh those that get uh those that jump off
in the middle that's all that is so Jade
wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Cole is in Salt Lake City hey
Cole welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you so much thanks for taking my
call sure how can I help
well I'm uh in an odd spot I have 55 000
of student debt from a previous career
and I'm in a new career and I'm finally
at a point where I can start paying it
back but I don't know if I should pay it
back really quick or I should sort of
spread it out and also try to save up
why do you want to stay in pain
and just stay in pain forever I want to
get rid of it
um my thought is I have previously gone
through uh a uh injury that cost a lot
of money that I didn't have at the time
and that some can be some and that I've
been I'm finally out of but that I
didn't get out from under for a while
okay so you want to make sure that I
think I hear what you're saying you're
like do I focus all of my money on this
student loan or do I you know try to
keep some aside for savings and make
sure that you don't hit a rough patch
again am I understanding that correctly
yes sorry I didn't say that well that's
okay so the way that we do this is we
want to make sure that we're like
focusing our intensity as powerfully as
possible in one area so that we can get
through it quickly right so to answer
your first question yes I think that you
should pay off these student loans as
quickly
as possible and the way to do that is to
make sure that you're focusing all of
your income effort towards that debt
does that make sense
that makes total sense what do you like
uh I'm going to be making 32 000 a year
as a graduate student
that feels low for me
uh it's I got a very good uh offer I
know let me say this I know other
graduate students in my field that are
making substantially less than that
you're you're studying to get a what
a PhD in geochemistry okay all right so
this is a fellowship program okay all
right cool and how much student loan
debt do you have
I have 55 000. okay and and this page
this having this gig obviously pays for
your PhD
yes yeah the PHD is in essence free and
then this is the money on top of that
yeah how long and and so you're doing
some uh proctoring and so forth as a
part of the gig too right
uh no actually I was given a fellowship
that is entirely research based so I am
okay but you're doing work for the
University obviously okay oh yes yeah
how long does that last until you're
how long does it take to get the PHD
yeah
four to six years I'm really hoping to
do it in four
yeah I'm aiming at four for sure so um
you don't have a lot of wiggle room in
living on thirty two thousand dollars
there's not a lot of you don't have a
lot of disposable income income left
over after food and rent right is your
rent free
um my rent is not free however it is
only four hundred and twenty dollars a
month thank goodness that's nice okay so
you got an unusually low rent that's
very good and that's I will be I'm going
to be living in a commune and we all
pool money for food so we can buy in
bulk okay wow that's helpful too okay
good for you well I'm gonna put as much
as I can reasonably towards the student
loan debt for the exact same reasons the
reason we're pausing is we expected this
what you were saying to have a higher
income as if you had graduated but now
you're still working on the PHD and it
changes the conversation but it's still
as quickly as you can get rid of the 55
000 the faster you get rid of it the
faster you prosper so back to Jade's
point this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
debt is smart investing is smart those
are both on the offensive side of the
money equation on the defensive side
there would be this thing called
Insurance
protecting your finances and uh hey you
got to have good offense and a good
defense if you want to win there's 10
kinds of insurance you might need based
on what your life looks like and we
built a coverage tool called the
coverage checkup it's completely free
and it allows you to really quickly
figure out what insurance you need what
insurance you don't need what you need
to upgrade and it'll automatically
connect you if you ask it to to the uh
Ramsey trusted insurance providers
ramseysolutions.com for the free checkup
ramsesolutions.com
checkup
ramsaysolutions.com slash
checkup make sure your defense is in
order Nate is in Austin Texas hi Nate
welcome to the Ramsay show
I appreciate it sure what's up
so I'm trying to find out about 12 years
of trying to convince my wife to let me
buy a flip house finally convince her
after saving up about fifty thousand
dollars to do so and she didn't want to
do it but she made me promise I wouldn't
uh try to rent it out that we would sell
it at the end of it after a three-month
construction duration That was supposed
to be this was this was back in November
of 21 I bought it and we're now a year
and a half later that three months has
turned into a year and a half
and finally after three three
contractors got the house finished and
put on the market in April and it's been
on the market for a little over 60 days
now with uh showing or two every other
week or every week and no offers
anything like that I've got the price
from 240 down to 217 and still not
seeing much more movement so this is
harder than they say on Tick Tock huh
there's a different different how much
have you lost all the idiots on Tick
Tock have to use residential contractors
too
yeah yeah yeah
it's easy I got 57 million dollars in 20
minutes and a bunch of crap okay
sorry Nate I've been right where you are
and it ain't no fun
let's go ahead I'm sorry no no I want to
know how much he's lost no he hadn't
lost anything yet he's not sold it he
hadn't sold it right so still still have
it and haven't sold it yet and and do
you have a mortgage on that property
personal property my my own home and
I've paid for paid cash for the rest of
it so I've got 157
000 in the HELOC that I owe and then the
rest was paid in cash yeah and I'm I'm
in it to at 221 right now so I'm
estimating with realtor fees and closing
costs it'll be about 241 that I'll be
all in
but you're on the market for 217.
I'll show you what you're going to lose
money yeah
definitely gonna lose money for sure
okay all right and because you've missed
you messed your estimates up uh and your
contractor choices up and so your
construction cost was way above what you
originally planned in your pro forma
well no my profile actually was uh 2 27
was what I was estimated to get then the
market went way up and then it went way
down and while I didn't go way down but
it's for some reason it's just not
selling the house there's a house three
three-story or three houses down that's
selling for 260 and it's it's on the
market for 260 and it's 200 square feet
less than this one so why why has
Insurance you should be giving yours
away at 217 why are people not crawling
all over it the Austin Market's not that
dead is the work is the workmanship not
good
well it's it's about an hour outside of
Austin it's not in Austin
um if the house down the street is worth
260 and you have yours at 200 square
feet Less on the mark 200 square feet
more on the market for 217. someone
should have snapped yours up in a
heartbeat
I would have thought the same thing my
realtor said that the the comps when we
were going through this was between 217
and 238 is what the comps were other
realtors that have come through said
it's a great price point at 225 and and
now I've dropped it down even more so I
don't know why it's not selling but I'm
trying to figure out if at this point do
I I've got about 50
000 in cash that's not gonna or
Investments that are not going to have a
penalty if I take it out I'm trying to
figure out do I pay down the HELOC and
just
uh wait wait it out or the hay lock is
independent of this decision it's on
your home
you could sell this house for ten
dollars and you still got the HELOC
well I would pay I would uh yeah I'm
just saying the interest rate in your
mind only are they connected well he's
just trying to think I don't want to
lose more money on interest having this
loan sit around I know correct okay so
the the all right number one you need to
get um jump online at Ramsey Solutions
and get in touch with a Ramsay trusted
endorsed local provider real estate
agent have them come out and look at it
because there's someone that's going to
have at least three years of experience
and they will have moved hundreds of
units not tens of units and they will be
able to give you some insight and you
may want to change real estate agents
again
um so first thing because the numbers
you're giving me don't make sense I
agree you the the a house does not vary
as much as it has in this conversation
and value why have they given you any
what you would call negative feedback as
to why why there's the variance there or
why it hasn't sold
so she's still saying that we're we're
within the right range and the only
there isn't anything like the house
looks good there's no concerns about the
house itself the neighborhood is up and
coming there's a lot of new builds the
house that's 260 was a new build mine
was a full renovation
um so that's a little bit of a
difference yeah they're not not it's not
a little bit of a difference it's a
completely different product they're not
comparables
you wouldn't use a new build as a comp
for a renovated old house they're not
comps so it's your earlier comparison
doesn't even hold water so it's about a
bad analysis okay so yeah I I think you
need to get some help and look uh
truly go to Ramsey Solutions and check
out Ramsay trusted person have them look
at it this is what I would personally do
and then based on what they're telling
me I'm I'm either going to change
Realtors and or I'm going to drop the
price when you pay down the HELOC you
can do that in three months four months
five months if you need to or you can
sell this house I'm Gonna Keep lowering
this house I mean if you've got to drop
it at 195 and get it gone get it gone
because here's the thing you have gone
to the school of life and you are paying
some stupid tuition
okay you did not analyze or understand
the marketplace for contractors you do
not know how to hire or manage
contractors you do not know how to run a
pro forma on a flip
because you didn't have any margin in
your flip your flip needed to have
another 25 margin that had you paid too
much for this thing going in considering
the amount of work you had to do to it
because your your margin after you sell
it is not anything you're not making
spit if your contractor said worked well
it wouldn't make spit and so you've got
to go back through and do an autopsy on
why this deal failed where you failed in
the process since you're going to pay 40
or 50 000 for this lesson learn the
lesson in detail in the most painful
lesson of all
is his wife gonna say I told you so
I told you you don't do this so you did
not put proper evaluation on the house
you underestimated the cost and you
underestimated how hard it was to deal
with contractors and you underestimate
the time it was going to take to flip it
and you underestimate that you were
going to continue to be in a white hot
Market that's three things I can tell
right now you didn't know the value you
thought you did you didn't know the heat
of the market and you thought you did
and you don't know how to deal with
contractors and you thought you did and
you missed your estimates on your
construction and you thought you did
those four things combined are going to
cost you 30 or 40 000 before you're done
if you're lucky only that but either way
sell the thing get rid of it dump you
can pay off the home equity loan then
it's just a matter of how much of your
cash you're going to lose you're going
to net 150 so your home equity loan is
gone it's just a matter of how much your
cash you're going to lose then the last
piece of this is this
I used to do crap like you did
only I did it to the tune of about four
million dollars worth and it caused me
to go bankrupt Nate that's why I got no
patience for it because I just exactly
only I was successful at flipping them
and making a profit but I had a lot of
short-term notes and the banks called my
notes I was 28 years old and bankrupted
me 30 years ago so I've learned my
lesson on doing flips with anything but
cash and I don't listen to people like
Tic Tac people that are doing real
estate seminars either I'm done with it
so those are the things I learned the
last one is this proverbs 31 says who
can find a virtuous wife for the heart
of her husband before she is she is more
valuable than rubies for the heart of
her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain I don't do
crap like this when my wife doesn't feel
good about it it costs me money every
time I do hmm
[Music]
foreign
flips for a second all right
all right since um gymnastics real
estate gymnastics doing flips is a big
deal
so I did my first flip
in
1983. the year before I was born so that
would be
30 years ago right or 40 years ago 40 40
years 40 years ago 40 years ago yeah the
first flip I did
I was so stupid
that I thought that everything that was
a foreclosure
was a good buy
that if it said foreclosure that it must
be cheap I equated foreclosure with
cheap which sometimes is true I think
most people do but I bought a HUD repo
they used to put them in the newspaper
and you would bid on them FHA Reef FHA
foreclosures HUD repo out of the news
you had a newspaper as a bid process I
turned in the bid I talked a banker into
financing 100 of it because I had a real
estate degree I was a real estate guy I
knew all about real estate and I was 23
years old so I was a freaking genius
okay
and so I bought this house
I knew everything about the house before
I bought it I'd gone through it with a
fine tooth comb okay the um
in those days they used uh we we used uh
uh copper pipes for the water supply and
the car the house had been sitting empty
and so the copper pipes had Frozen and
split
and so it was pretty much a sprinkler
system underneath and you had to go
through and redo the copper pipes and I
knew how to do that because I'd done
Renovations work in high school working
for my dad in real estate business so I
crawled around on my little back under
there with a little torch and fixed all
of the spliced all these pipes fixed all
the pipes uh put new carpet in it went
in on the weekends and Sharon and I
repainted it okay and I kept all of my
receipts for what I spent and paid
myself zero labor okay that's how stupid
I was
and we put the house on the market
and it sold in five weeks so I'm a huge
success
net net net net net when I got done
I added up what we had in it what we
paid for the closing costs what we paid
on the closing cost on the resale what
actual after every dollar is recorded
what actual net profit that I make
842 dollars you're an overnight success
I'm now a game on can't nobody tell you
obviously good at this
which means that I probably paid myself
what a dollar an hour labor yeah well
you know I didn't get paid for the labor
the 842 was with this free labor I had I
had slave labor me yeah and my wife yeah
so we're in there so that was job one
okay the next one I will I bought and I
thought I'm not buying any houses in bad
neighborhoods because I don't know
anything about all that stuff I'll get
in trouble but this guy called me up and
he had a house and he sold it to me for
seven thousand dollars
and I ran the in what I thought was the
estimate and I had three contractors
look at it and give us bids and uh the
first contractor wanted a fifteen
hundred dollar deposit up front
never saw him again right
went to his trailer and knocked on the
door in the trailer park trying to get
my fifteen I wonder what I didn't get
shot by the way he had already left and
gone to Kalamazoo or wherever it is
contractors go when they take your
fifteen hundred dollars because you're
an idiot and you give it to him up front
yeah and so then I started on the
second contractor the third contractor
the fourth contractor and uh when I
finished with that property
it I had already done a whole bunch of
other deals by then uh like uh 60 or 80
more deals oh my gosh by the time I
finished that property I ended up only
losing fourteen thousand dollars on a
house I paid seven thousand for four and
a half years later oh my gosh this is
how dumb I am so if that wait if that's
something else had been your first house
I would have been out of business yeah I
would have been Nate yeah you would have
been like I'm never doing this my wife
would have been going yeah
instead I managed to delay the pain on
that one meanwhile doing a whole bunch
of others and I made a lot of money yeah
I made a lot of money I ended up in my
life I have owned over 2 000 pieces of
real estate I flipped real estate as my
job for four years by I was using 90 day
notes to fix them and flip them I made
and I started buying property at 70
cents on the dollar minus repairs
wow so a hundred thousand dollar
property I buy it for 70 minus the
repairs that was the formula and that
means I bought a lot of foreclosures a
lot of Estates I did some historic
rehabs we've done a bazillion deals I
can walk around Nashville and say I did
that house that house that house that
house 30 40 years later I want to take
that tour and uh now you don't want to
be in that neighborhood probably but um
okay some of those neighborhoods are now
gentrified but um gotcha they've come
back a long way from seven thousand
dollars now it's 260 to live on that
street and it's a great property not
really still in Dodge City the shoot up
down the street of Dodge City I don't
care whether it's gentrified or not so
anyway the uh you're killing me here but
yeah so this is this is my real estate
career so when I get aggravated at the
idiots on Tic Tac it's because I was one
of them yeah okay I was doing the exact
same stuff and I can smell
neophyte
beginner a mile away yeah because I was
I was I was 23 I was going to get rich
in real estate I made 842 dollars minus
the cost of my labor I lost 14 000 and
then I went on to make money and make
money and I started figuring it out that
I had to you know I had I had to I had
to be tough with contractors I had to
get with good ones and and I had to have
be tough on schedules you had to be
finished and then you put the house on
the market aggressively and you flip it
you don't keep it ever and uh you know
not like her we're not in the rental
business and then then I ended up buying
a bunch of property I buy packages of
houses about 10 or 20 at once and they
were rental portfolio and I lost every
bit of that when I went bankrupt in uh
in 1988 five years later I have now own
I had four million dollars worth of real
estate when we went in that's a fast one
in a bankruptcy yeah that's a whirlwind
day it was I worked all the time and I
was really really good at doing deals
but I'm saying to go for from Zero to
Hero or hero to zero and back Zero to
Hero to zero that's a PhD in d u m b is
what that is yeah and so but I got a
lifetime of learning there and it led me
to have a bullcrap meter that is very
sensitive to real estate people and uh
so you know when you guys start talking
about real estate real estate real
estate because real estate's real hot
right right it's a popular fad topic
again everybody wants to do a real
estate deal everybody wants to do a flip
everybody wants to own a real estate and
your renters will pay your rent rentals
will pay the payment you don't worry
about it it says people who've never had
renters that's a dumb butt statement
okay let me tell you let me teach you
some words chapter 13. bankruptcy for I
will pay you when by God I want to
okay and let me tell you what you can do
with a tenant who's in a bankruptcy
nothing wow you have a stay on you which
is an injunction a federal court has
looked at you like a dog and said stay
and as a creditor if you even call your
tenant you can be held in contempt of
court wow you cannot talk to them you
cannot do anything except everything
they wish as far as repairs while they
pay zero rent because you stay dog stay
yeah you learn this when you've had a
couple of them so when renters are
always they're going to pay the payment
and it's a free house and I'm I you know
I have a jet airplane and you're just an
idiot you're just an idiot on Tick Tock
that's what you are it's unbelievable
well here so real real estate is great
but you there's a people factor with the
contractors there's a people factor with
the renters there's a people Factor when
I overestimate how what the uh how how
much money I'm gonna make I
underestimate the contractor or the time
it's going to take to run it I I I think
it's going to sell faster than it is
because I'm always a glass half full guy
and right before that's when you get
your freaking nose bloodied slow down
people pay cash for this stuff and run
it like a business not like a get rich
quick scheme it's your only hope of
doing making money in real estate that
is not a poor man's game I think that's
the part that anybody can take away from
this is it would be one thing Dave I
feel like if you were sitting here going
I tried that really real estate thing
and this is what happens and it was just
like this negative story but then you go
on and figure out the best way to do
this the smarter way to do it the way
that actually works and that's what
you're teaching it's not like you're
saying stay away from Real Estate never
do it there's just a right and a wrong
way to do it I was 24 years old I had a
million dollar net worth in 1984 and I
made 250 000 that year that's 20 000
bucks a month in 1984. okay in 1988 my
taxable income was six thousand dollars
Wow all I did was sell property and
bankruptcy this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money Joanna's with
us in New York hi Joanna welcome with
Ramsay show
Hey Jake hey Jade I'm a little
Starstruck right now so
we're honored to have you how can we
help
okay so the facts simply Dave are I'm a
55 year old single mom and I have an
incredible job and I make a an amazing
salary
um and I am in debt to my salary uh not
proudly and it took a lot of Humble Pie
to call it today
um
but anyways it's really been hard and
I'm just trying to find out in my
journey of this death snowball
would I stop the 401K I'm matching it
six percent to get my company match
and put my two 401K loans that I took to
the top of the snowball and I'm very
embarrassed I'm sorry to call that's
okay you're fine
hey believe me the dumbest person on
this call is me I've done dumber and
you've done so we're okay you're gonna
make it you're in third place you're
gonna make it Joanna you're in third
place it's Dave me and then you okay so
what's your what's your salary
uh I make uh with overtime it will over
time depend on about 140 and I am an
executive assistant good for you well
done yeah well done how much how much
data have you got
uh so uh between uh and I'm also breast
cancer survivor way to go
um well yeah man go keep on keeping on
and I am doing it
um some about 156 in Consumer Debt
including the medical and the 401ks and
I owe 247 on the house
okay uh break the 156 down for me a
little bit how much on the 401K
my 401k and I do from a former job have
about 40K in like a 403 b thing I don't
know any money not in retirement
uh uh that would be negative Dave
so what is the other hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars
uh well it is a fair amount of survival
as a single mom it is a lot of stupid
and
um really bad not what caused it what
kind of debt is it credit card debt and
how much credit card I got
uh probably uh a hundred and no no no
I'm sorry are you about
uh 80 on credit cards and the rest would
be the cards the cars
yeah plural
how many cars do you have
we have one paid for the car and we have
two I'm paying on currently why so many
cars are you paying are you buying your
kids cars
well yes that's exactly right so they my
daughter just graduated college and she
is a teacher and we have the student
loan debt oh and part of that is that my
um
a piece of the student loan that I am
helping her that I agree to do right
um
how expensive is your daughter's car
that's in your name
uh uh we owe 15 000 on that one and what
do you owe on your car
I just
is about twenty four thousand okay and
uh what about the other car
the other party was paid for why who
drives that my son drives that and uh
he's in school right now and working at
school right now so he's in Pennsylvania
away from us and so he's in college
yes and what is that car worth
uh I uh honestly probably about 7 500 I
would imagine it's a Subaru okay
all right
um are are you are you ready to fix this
um are you kidding um are you ready to
fix this enough that I can tell you the
truth
yeah I'm ready okay
uh single mom super mom you don't get to
take care of everybody else anymore
you're a freaking broke person
yep these are grown children and they
need to be grown adults now and they
need to take care of themselves you
cannot continue to support everybody you
are broke
okay you're broke and you have to start
acting like you're broke and quit buying
people twenty four thousand dollar cars
that are college graduates that are
teachers
they buy their own freaking car and they
about to give you back this one so you
can sell it yep she needs to go get her
a car or if she wants to go down the
bank and get a loan and pay you off and
buy this car for what you owe on it
that'll be great too but otherwise this
car needs to go bye-bye
seriously you're not going to do that
but this is what you should do
okay because you have a pat listen
you've been compensating and taking care
of these babies because you are a super
mom
after the divorce for a long time and I
just told you to stop and it's gonna be
very hard for you to stop
right I mean if you get your your if you
get your think about this for a second
you get your daughter's car back it's
15K your car's 24K you get back the car
that other son is driving you drive that
cash car and he gets something he gets a
beater that he saves up space with cash
for think about that's almost forty
thousand dollars
uh Joanna when you get to call when you
went to college did your dad give you a
car
uh no
LeBron
when I went to college if I wanted to go
it had to be in something I owned mm-hmm
it wasn't that people didn't send me
this stuff to come right it wasn't yeah
that was that's what most people grew up
with so yeah you're not abusing her
you're not being unkind and then we're
going to start taking care of Joanna
because Joanna is actually a hero you've
done an amazing job raising these kids
you've survived breast cancer you've
moved yourself into a six-figure income
in New York you grew up in the Bronx
you're not an amazing life you got a
hero story if you have a hero story and
so it's time to live your hero story
it's time for you to go take care of you
and that's not selfish it's you're
overdue about a hundred thousand dollars
worth of overdue and so I really really
want you to tear into this so what we're
going to do is we're going to do low car
shuffling we're going to chop up all the
credit cards and uh Jade and I are going
to put you into Financial Peace
University and
um we're gonna also put you with a coach
that's in the area that's a Ramsay coach
and we're going to pay for every bit of
it because if you've got a coach in your
corner and you'll go through Financial
Peace University and you'll do the stuff
we'll teach you to do you can clean this
up in a couple years and yes you do need
to temporarily stop your 401k but that's
a minor thing out of this whole thing
the big deal is is you've got to make
all of the dollars that you have uh
take care of Joanna the hero put them to
work you do and you deserve that yeah
you deserve it you've been working so
hard
exactly exactly that I think that people
forget what they deserve out of this and
like what you owe this to yourself you
owe it to yourself to be able to not
have to take care of you yeah yes get
your crap together
and let them get theirs that'd be a good
thing it'll be great for those young
people and you have done a great job you
got them both up and both into college
and through college that's pretty strong
yes well done they would rather
years than have cars now
there you go mic drop
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
warshaw joined of course by Dave Ramsey
and we're taking your calls all hour
give us a call Triple eight eight two
five five two two five and we will take
your call we've got mark on line three
what's going on mark from Minneapolis
Minnesota
thanks for taking my call no problem
honor to speak to you how can we help
um
my mother passed away oh I'm so sorry
left yeah thanks I appreciate that
um but she left a inheritance for my
sister and I uh a house an investment
account and some cash wow um she yeah
it's very nice and
um she back in the
20 years ago when my father passed away
she had put our the my sister and my
names on each one of those accounts with
her but she did not have a will and she
sort of
explicitly defined who got what
um
so my question is she you know and I
know it's only been a couple months so I
don't want to be you know insensitive
about this but she's kind of deciding if
she wants to keep the house or not I
don't really have any reason to I live
in another state I you know sentimental
value is a house that my mom and dad
built but she she uh she but she's
thinking that she might want to keep
that I don't know how long it's going to
take her to decide this and it might be
a while because she's got some things
going on in her life now it's just the
two of you or is there other siblings
nope it's just the two of us okay yeah
okay so the house is worth what
the house is worth 300. okay what is the
rest of the rest of the assets worth
yeah the Investments are worth 300 and
um the cash is about a hundred thousand
okay so your assumption is we're gonna
split this in half if she takes the
house she'll take the Investments and
y'all split the cash
that's that would be the ultimate
solution in my head yeah I mean that's a
fair trade I mean it should be split
down the middle if you don't even though
she doesn't have a will if you don't
agree to split it down the middle the
courts will tell you to
they're going to split it evenly Among
The Heirs
and they're going to force the sale of
the house to do that
just realistically how long should I
give her to decide one way or the other
um I I mean it sounds like you have a
tenuous relationship with her or you're
afraid she's in a very tender place and
you don't want to
she's struggling with something you said
she's got stuff going on I don't know
what that means yeah it's well she yeah
she's thinking she's been telling me
over the last couple years that she's
thinking about you know maybe getting a
divorce and then she would move into
that house and take that over because it
would be a perfect house for us if
that's what she decided to do so the
house is empty
the house is empty right now too right
yeah
okay
um well we're not going to wait on a
divorce to be final
right that's a good point her decision's
got to be her decision yeah and not
continue she needs to is you said Texas
um Minnesota is that where she is
that's where she is and that's where the
house is as well
correct okay I don't know Minnesota law
and I'm not a lawyer anyway have her
check Minnesota law but in most States
if you inherit a house from your mom and
get divorced they do not split that
house with your spouse
and by the way she's already inherited
it so she can't get away from it so but
I would imagine she is that is protected
in the event of a divorce I but again
you need to check me I'm not an illegal
scholar okay so uh but but she for her
sake so what I would do is just say uh
Hey listen I don't want to get all up in
your business or anything we probably
ought to just settle this estate right
quick if you want the house an easy way
to do this is I'll just you know we'll
go to court we'll go to the Probate
Court get them to deed the house to you
and
um and I'll take the Investments and
we'll split the hundred thousand fifty
thousand each and um and we'll get this
thing settled up we need to wrap it up
though uh it doesn't need to drag out
it's not good for the house to sit there
empty without us knowing what's going on
you need a plan and so I think it's good
for you
did you say she's been saying for
several years she's going to get a
divorce did you say that he
yeah yeah she's a kicked the can down
the road girl
she'll kick this can down the road for a
decade
if you let her so that's what I'm afraid
it's good for her and good for you
to gently be the proactive one that
helps her make decisions because she
doesn't like to make decisions
yeah so I'm just gonna have to kind of
make that decision regardless of yeah I
mean I'm going to leave that I'll just
say we need to split this up exactly I'm
gonna have to decide one word yeah let's
let's go ahead and get this done I think
we can wrap it up in about 90 days if
you want the house do you want the house
or do you have you decided if not let me
know by the end of the week
go ahead and contact an attorney over
there and find out what probate looks
like because you have to go before the
Probate Judge to get all this verified
even though there's not a will and
you'll you'll fill out affidavits and
you'll probably pay a thousand bucks out
of the hundred uh in attorney's fees to
run it through probate and get the judge
to approve all the transactions and the
split uh but it shouldn't be it's kind
of a no-brainer it's fairly easy it's
open shut as long as she's in agreement
if she's not in agreement we got to sell
the house
right and then we split everything down
the middle the proceeds of the house the
investment account the hundred thousand
okay that's right then that's on that's
kind of where I was leaning I just
didn't know if I needed the presser I I
wouldn't trust her in a mean way I would
just say hey I talked to an attorney
looks like we can get this done in about
30 days we just got to decide what we're
going to do I know you might want the
house you've talked about that if you
want it I'm happy to let you have it if
that's good for you I'll take the
Investments of 300 the house is worth
about 300 and we'll split the 100 and
the attorney says we can wrap that up in
about 90 days or whatever the attorney
tells you and it's just fair you're just
very helpful and you're proactive and
you're upbeat and it's not like you need
to get this dude or not like you're
pressing her she's the one who said that
she you're helping her wanted the house
yeah you're helping her and you're
helping get it done and helping all
those decisions be made and if you don't
want the house it's okay just tell me
we'll put it on the market and we'll
sell it and it's okay you know because I
don't want it and you know and we'll
just split the money and if you'd rather
have the money in the house it's okay
but we got to kind of decide because we
need to get this going and so I got the
attorney moving and just let me know
what you want to do and it's just real
helpful and and just put a little energy
behind the decision and because
um she um I'll give you a guess and I'm
just playing uh Dr John deloney my best
best version here
um that she has a lot of fear and she
operates in fear so decisions are hard
for her
I think that's exactly right yeah yeah I
think that I think you hit the the nail
right on the head yeah she's been living
in a toxic environment for a long time
I'm sad for her right yeah that's awful
and you want to be gentle and kind but
it's not being gentle and kind to play
that game with her
true
yeah yeah that makes good sense too yeah
speed efficiency with a smile is very
gentle look that house could be a new
beginning for her it could be she moves
on could be that she finally makes a
decision to make her marriage work I
hope that works that too I hope he does
or something like maybe he knows she's
got options now
that is true I don't know what it is but
um hopefully the best you know it's just
um
these things where you don't deal with
things
never means that you don't deal with
them it just means you deal with them
later yeah that's true so deal with them
yeah deal with it now put a bow on it
every time you got a decision like this
and you can do it kindly and you can do
it with compassion you just lost your
parents I mean oh my gosh it's so
painful yeah horrible time to go through
and it's it's a very nostalgic to walk
through the house you know and it brings
back good and bad memories I'm sure
would for most people and so that's all
cool but yeah just gently and kindly
move her right along and
um I don't think she's going to dig her
heels in I don't think so it I mean the
way he said it it sounded like hey I I
you know if we're if we're dividing this
up I'd like to have the house and he's
like okay great like it luckily for them
if you don't it's okay we're gonna get
on the market and the attorney says we
can get it sold and we'll just split up
the proceeds and travel approve it and
it's all good they're lucky that there's
no animosity
house sitting empty in Minneapolis in
the winter
that's called frozen pipes that's called
issues yeah you got hardwood's gone bad
I got leaks I got all kinds of things
I'm thinking oh man yeah that can become
a headache I don't know anything about
anything but it could be the heat bills
are high there in the winter I don't
know I'm from Tennessee what do I know
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
perfect
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Brent and Natasha are with us hey
guys how are you hello good evening
welcome welcome where do you live
Seymour Indiana okay and what is that
near Indianapolis oh good okay fine well
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you guys paid
276 350. excellent how long did this
take uh a little over a little under
five years and your range of income
during that time uh 147
000 to 178 000. cool what do you all do
for a living I am a uh deviation
investigator for a pharmaceutical
company and I am a first grade teacher
awesome
have you guys welcome thank you five
years 276 thousand dollars worth of debt
what kind of debt was this a little bit
of everything uh credit cards uh 40 uh
401k loan uh car uh house you paid off
your house
yes so what's this house worth
um it's uh I think now that last I
checked it was a little a little over
three hundred thousand okay cool and how
much do you guys have in your
Investments
um the last I checked it mine was almost
600 000 I think yours was almost two
hundred thousand so show your baby steps
millionaires yes
how old are you guys I'm 47. I'm 46. wow
so you did it quick good for y'all well
done very well done I love it so good so
tell us the story what happened five
years ago that put you on this track to
be millionaires well um 200 or 2018
um
when we first got married I started
doing all the financial stuff and
when we got it got to a point where
Natasha wanted to see everything and I I
could I uh hadn't taken care of it as
well as I could so I you know we were
piled up some debt so uh once we got
there and she met with her financial
advisor and she suggested we take FPU
and we went through that and the rest is
history well thanks to the financial
advisor yes very good okay so uh Natasha
what was scratching in the what was
itching in the back of your head you're
wanting to scratch I want to see what's
going on here I know um I just think
being left in the dark and when he told
me that we how much we were in debt it
just terrified me immensely and
um guilt not being involved throughout
our marriage and
um how long you've been married 22 years
22 years okay yes and so you've gone
you've gone 17 years yeah yeah I think
uh I'm a big Warrior and so he
pick it upon himself in our household so
which I do not advise how much of it was
the non-mortgage debt about eight
seventy to eighty thousand
yes yeah so yeah very good so the cool
thing is now that you're doing it
together there's no worry nope right you
know when you know it's actually knowing
what's going on even if you find out
there's 80 000 in debt once you know it
and that's the whole thing yeah and it's
easier to face the monster once you know
once you know how big he is you know
right he's a lot bigger when he's in the
dark yes yes
that's good good for y'all well done
okay so you the financial advisor says
go through Financial Peace University
what was your first reaction when you
heard that uh definitely because I was
terrified what about you Brian oh
definitely I was I was on board because
it was a
the financial issues we had were kind of
a weighing down on my shoulders so yeah
getting that off my shoulders I mean it
was a relief to go through fbu so and
learn how to work together and carry it
together yeah right yeah correct and
again the monster and the light is not
nearly as big a deal correct all right
good for y'all well done that's fine hey
man after 17 years of marriage you
learned a whole new dance okay yes
that's a good dance trick right there
yes look if you learn to communicate
around your money what you guys learned
to do is like you can communicate
through anything right yeah yes and you
guys have seen that play off play out in
real time that's very very very cool
right proud of y'all well done no house
payment or anything yes I mean you got
nothing to worry about yeah that still
really hasn't sunk in yet cause it's
only been a few months so yeah I mean
what's the celebration you pay off your
house you got to go do something cool
well we're going to take a vacation so
um our daughter just graduated high
school so um our other daughter so um we
kind of let her pick so we're going to
Disney World okay so we we haven't been
on vacation in a long time and you're
bringing everybody so the four of us
okay yes and then when you get home pick
an adult vacation
and and go on one of those too yes yeah
yes absolutely oh my goodness hate mail
from all the Disney adults and I truly
don't care okay support this message I
support it I don't I don't care at all
my daughter my daughter included okay so
hey guys that's right my
30-something-year-old daughter I should
make sure I say but yeah they lived in
the house too so the daughters get to go
on the one vacation and then they go on
another vacation
so what you need to celebrate and then
you need to celebrate some more
yes
yes you say all right I go to that first
class in Financial Peace University and
we're both on board I don't want to
carry the weight anymore I don't want to
worry anymore where the words you all
you two used
um what were the things you started
learning in there that made you believe
this is happening it's doable we're
gonna be okay
I think it was just a lot of
communication and we had to learn from
each other and it's just that
once you like like you said once you see
the Monster you understand what's going
on and and you can take care of it and
you know and we had good jobs so we knew
we could yeah you're making good money
yeah right making too much money to be
broke yeah right right and just we were
just dead set I mean I'm doing this and
do you remember one of the lessons that
stuck out
ah
been a couple years ago yeah it's been a
little bit oh yes I mean there wasn't
there wasn't really One Singular aha
moment then I don't I don't think so no
I think it was just the whole program
yeah the proven system right yes
we're going to do this yeah we're going
to communicate we're going to carry it
together we're going to attack this
monster he's going down yeah I guess
good good I like that I like that that's
acceptable and that is a great result
that's what we hope for with Financial
Peace University and it's what happens
for the people that engage so excellent
excellent very well done y'all very cool
yeah you know I've asked you before I'm
asking one more time
you're a hundred percent
out of debt right that's a 47 year old
yes baby steps millionaires
how's that feel wonderful yes yes but I
mean just
yeah no worries for our daughters
just
we did it yeah yeah touchdown yeah
well done I'm so proud of you thank you
we did they're neat people you deserve
it
but got y'all out there you work too
hard to be broke yes you know you put up
with crap you know you go to the office
and you go yeah man I go to work
yeah still like I mean you know the P
the things you have to deal with you
know you work too hard to be broke you
might as well win while you're at it you
know that's right oh my gosh I'm so
proud of y'all I'm so glad for natural
Peace University helped very very good
absolutely all right and uh your
daughter's name is what that's with you
Claire and Claire is how old she is 13.
okay so she's 13. yeah and then uh then
the other one is in college you said oh
she's going she's heading to college in
August yes Emma yes okay so cool very
cool all right we've got the live and
give box for you the baby steps
Millionaire's book since you are one The
Total Money Makeover book for you to
give away to somebody and a Financial
Peace University membership since you've
been there you can give that to someone
blessing blessings to some other people
will let it pay let you pay it forward
at our behest and we'll just say giving
that to you to say we're proud of you
good work thank you very good work all
right Brent and Natasha and Claire from
Indianapolis area
276 000 paid off in five years making
147 to 178 baby steps millionaires at 47
years old this stuff works count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
one two three
[Applause]
yeah
yeah you gotta love it boys and girls
you gotta love it
well you can talk about your series
or you can talk about people who really
do things like Brent and Natasha they
are people that do things this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
for you
our scripture of the day First
Corinthians 13 13 and now these three
remain Faith open love but the greatest
of these is love
Miss opal Lee the grandmother of
Juneteenth said if people can be taught
to hate they can be taught to love and
changing Minds can actually be done it's
not going to happen in a day you got to
work at it a way to go Miss opal love it
good stuff open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five a lot
of you are planning to move sometime
soon and that's awesome I'm excited for
you but I got to be real in most places
around the country you're going to be
facing some sky-high home prices and
interest rates aren't returning to their
record lows anytime soon this does not
make home ownership impossible
makes it very possible if you want to
buy or sell you got to make sure you're
financially ready and uh you got to have
a trusted and experienced real estate
agent to walk you through it not a
family friend who just got their license
or some pretty smart nice person no no
someone who does Real Estate not as a
hobby if you've sold two houses this is
not who you want selling your largest
asset a suite everybody has to start
there but that's not what you're going
to do you're going to get a high quality
high octane high protein Ramsey trusted
agent through our endorsed local
providers program and we vet the agents
from around the country so you'll have
the best support whether you're moving
from Florida to Alaska or buying your
first home somewhere in between go to
ramsaysolutions.com agent and find a
Ramsey trusted real estate agent today
ramseysolutions.com agent Jacob is in
Atlanta hi Jacob welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Dave and Jade thank you so much for
taking my call it's an honor to speak
with you you too what's up
is it okay if I give a little bit of
background information before my
question quickly
sure so I'm 24 years old and I'm
self-employed for the past three years
I've been running an online business and
it takes about 20 hours per week for me
I believe I could manage this while
working a full-time job to start a
long-term career currently my business
brings in about 4 500 per month and
using the first five months of this year
for reference this November I'm getting
married and my fiance and I are looking
for homes in the 300 to 350 000 price
range we're putting 150 000 down and
aiming to pay the mortgage off in three
to four years depending on how much we
borrow pretty good fiance is awesome
thank you my fiance is also
self-employed and she brings in about 4
000 per month so our combining comes
about 8 500. so since we're looking to
pay off the mortgage so quickly I'm
looking at some sort of uh longer term
career and then also doing my
self-employed business on the side but
with no normal nine to five work
experience I'm a bit unsure on what kind
of role would be a good fit for me I do
have a degree in exercise and sports
science but I'm interested in pursuing
business and when it comes to applying
for more advanced business positions do
you think I'll have a chance at
competing at those
what are you doing online
uh it's just mainly e-commerce so I sell
on platforms like eBay and Amazon and it
doesn't take up too much time because I
have places that fulfill my orders for
me so it's mainly just buying online
Like A Drop Shipping business
uh it I guess you could say that but I
buy the inventory and then ship it to
platforms like Amazon that store it for
me and then they ship it out so normally
Drop Shipping is where they purchase an
item and then they ship it direct I I
normally hold a little bit of inventory
are you not interested in growing that
business
well I am interested in growing that
business and it's been growing steadily
but it just doesn't take up too much my
time and I'm looking for more if you
spent more time on it would it grow
yes it would grow but the thing is with
that it's going to consistently require
me to put more cash into it which I
would like to stay around how much cash
I currently have in the business liquid
which is around 50 000 and then use
extra sources of income to help pay down
the mortgage faster plus I'm interested
in starting some sort of new career if
that makes sense
so the answer then to my question is no
you're not interested in growing that
business you'd like it right where it's
at yeah I'm happy to where it's at yes
okay
um here's I I'll just tell you what's
running through my head and I may or not
may or may not be true okay sometimes
um when you've got a uh uh you have this
thing you grew up out and you're young
and you started real young uh and you're
making really good money it feels like
it's not real and like you didn't do
anything and there's like you're uh it's
like this is a kid job working at the
mall or something for you and you want a
big boy job as if what you're doing at
forty five hundred dollars a month is
not a big boy job I just want to go
ahead and affirm you you already have a
big boy job you're making more than some
folks making their business a lot of
people making their quote unquote real
job unquote you know so I don't want you
to think that what's running through my
head is I think I I'm a little bit
afraid and I'm not sure I'm not accusing
you this but I don't I'm a little bit
afraid you might think that working for
someone is going to be like a lot cooler
than it is
that yeah that's a good point I think
part of it is the stability because the
items that I'm selling they are very
seasonal so the average that I'm giving
you is accounting for like Q4 as
examples which obviously is way hotter
for buying or back to school times or
even the beginning of the year
is much slower could you expand into
items that are less seasonal and more
everyday use or every you know every
season
yes that is also a possibility but I'm
not requiring you to do that I just
don't want you to
Overlook the diamonds at your feet while
you're looking over here in the corner
for something else and that's all works
that's all that's why we keep coming
back to this because what you're doing
is pretty impressive in other words
from what I hear from this it when
you're starting a business sometimes the
hardest part is getting it going and
starting to create a profit and you've
already got it going so that's why I
kept going back to it because it's can
you get a job doing project management
or e-retailing or e-tailing for some
company making 50 or 80 000 bucks yeah
maybe you probably can you probably talk
somebody into that right now and you can
go do it and you're gonna be working for
some goofball possibly who's having
trouble making payroll Friday because he
doesn't manage his cash well I mean so
it's not always you know or some startup
that goes broke because of venture
capitalists pulled the rug out from
under them or whatever the thing is I
mean it's not always uh Everything That
Glitters Is Not Gold so uh yeah go do
that and get you some experience doing
that but I I I just want to affirm you
that you've already done something that
some of the people you are going to work
for don't even know how to do
and that's what that's all I'm saying
yeah you know just just keep that in
mind while you're doing this and set
your expectations reasonably and um like
are you somehow uh less than if you
can't get a job making 60 or 80 grand to
an e-tailing yeah for somebody uh
working with their you know their social
media team or whatever their eBay team
whatever helping them do stuff no you're
not but you have you have plenty of
shops to come to work at Ramsey for
instance uh we've got a huge you know
digital we got almost 1100 people in
here a thousand people in here and uh uh
you know a large number of them are
dealing with the web and technology and
marketing and digital marketing and so
on and you're capable of joining those
teams you've already got the chops and
regardless of what your particular or
four-year degree was in the thing I
do is if he does go pursue something out
there that he doesn't let what he's
built go by the wayside in any way not
too easily and just you know his whole
thing was I got to pay off the house I
got to pay off the house and he's he's
young guy he's 22 years old like he'll
he'll pay the house off I just don't
want him to make this decision purely
from that standpoint yeah you know yeah
go ahead and do what's right for your
career and get around to the house as is
it proper yeah you're going to be with
yourself doing what's right for you and
your future and the future of your wife
and that what's going to build us the
life we want and as a part of that we're
going to make money we're going to pay
off the house yeah I'm gonna make money
that's for sure he knows how to make
money yeah and he's gonna be all right
you know you and I both recognize that
as entrepreneurs when you and Sam run a
business for years and it's funny you
can see somebody that some people you
can't beg them to go make money a lot of
people you can't keep them from it
that's right that's why you know I
didn't want to try to tell them hey
don't do this do that but I'm what he's
got right there like you said it's
diamonds at his feet and he's doing what
most people
haven't been able to figure out I want
to side hustle I can live on 4 500 bucks
okay yeah there you go I know that's
right there you go so hey good job man
proud of you keep it up hope that works
good for you
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books Austin man I tell you what
great job in there Ben and uh of course
Zach and of course James well done guys
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]